let's talk about the uh the
ramifications of the binding
administration's policies in one of the
most ridiculous ways we can from the st
louis fed on twitter they say from the
fred block
a thanksgiving dinner serving of poultry
costs a dollar forty two a soybean based
dinner serving with the same amount of
calories cost 66 cents and provides
almost twice twice as much protein now
they're not saying outright
don't buy turkey but we get what they're
saying now hold on it would not be
an establishment if the media did not
jump in and join in as well so google
search
don't buy turkeys and what do you see
well here's from mahoning matters
there's no turkey shortage but don't
wait to buy from the des moines register
why is there a turkey shortage then from
consumer reports there is no turkey
shortage followed by pita who tells you
not to eat turkey so uh the prices are
going up yeah we we went to uh we got a
fresh turkey went to a farm and we
pre-ordered
like they actually raised a turkey from
june and got all big and then
this past sunday uh and they told us
you can't get them in most places if you
want a turkey good luck and now that's
why the media is telling people hey hey
hey don't get mad you're not having
turkey for thanksgiving you don't want
turkey anyway right hey this soy stuff
is cheaper and better for you how about
that now that and people say to me
that's not joe biden's fault this is
happening and i've said over and over
again i've done long segments talking
about why it is joe biden's fault one of
which is the inflation gas prices
speculation i can get into it but let me
ask you because you know you're you're
the economics guy what what is it with
with the bite administration that's
resulting in inflation high gas prices
food shortages
what is it
let me let me take you back to 2016 and
in the trump campaign and we had a
mantra
there uh the way we were going to grow
the economy and it was simple it was uh
tax cuts
not to benefit the corporations but but
simply to encourage them to bring jobs
on shore was deregulation to lower the
costs
and make us more globally competitive it
was
energy independence
and and cheap energy which again is
makes us more competitive puts more
money in consumers pockets to help them
be able to buy more and increase their
wages and most of all it was
fair trade it was it was stopping the
the attacks not just by china on us but
india europe and everywhere else where
we had the lowest tariffs in the world
everybody was taking advantage of us now
all of those tim are what we call
structural changes in the economy
designed to increase
growth and do it in a way where the the
productivity would increase and
therefore wage real wages would rise and
inflation would be held down that's the
that's the structural macroeconomic
approach to prosperity now if you think
about what went before that and what has
come after that that answers your
question before that
what what what the biden obama
administration did for eight years was
double
double the national debt from 10 to 20
trillion dollars think about that it
went from 10 trillion dollars to 20
trillion dollars that was pure what we
call in economics pure keynesian
stimulus designed to stimulate the
economy but it didn't work because they
didn't address the underlying structural
changes all we got was this i know if
you remember the phrase the new normal
this was like slow growth and stagnant
wages okay so we come to trump things
boom and then biden takes over what has
he done
he's reversed all four
points of the trump economic growth
compass right he wants to raise taxes
right he's slamming on more regulations
he's made just the worst
mockery and ruin uh of our energy policy
and and now we're begging the saudis uh
to pump oil uh i'll try a little
comedy's always hard but but here's a
little comedy for you uh it it at the
football game tailgates now before the
games they're eating caviar because it's
cheaper than cooking hot dogs with
propane right there's wings shortages
yes and there's wing shortages and then
the other the other thing is like my job
at the white house as i talk about the
interim time book was supply chains
right if you have your manufacturing
here
and
your supply chains will stay here those
are resilient if you send your factories
offshore here's the thing
supply chains follow them right and
therefore you have fragile supply chains
the best broken ones at worst and so
what's happening with with the biden
economy right now
is uh there's not enough attention being
paid to making it here uh the the this
is like i actually wrote the order for
the keystone pipeline when we first got
in it was the coolest thing um it was
what it happened early but it was cool i
i literally did this in 20 minutes it
was probably the fastest executive work
ever written right but but but biden
undid that quicker right the stroke of
the pen
and so go ahead the keystone pipeline i
think is the best is the easiest way to
explain to people the rise in prices
yeah so the first thing you'll get from
like usa today is they'll say biden's
policies are not causing gas and prices
to increase they're not causing
inflation and then when you when when it
comes to the keystone pipeline they'll
say the pipeline wasn't set to deliver
oil for some time anyway so shutting it
down had no impact on the amount of
energy we had but what it did is that it
signaled to many investors and many
companies the supply chain for oil is
not going to meet
the requirements in the coming years
which which means
buy now because those prices are going
up speculators then start buying up in
fear that we won't have enough in the
future so the prices instantly start
spiking then when gas prices start
spiking the cost of everything goes up
right afterwards you got to drive to
work well i need more money for work
boss because the gas is too expensive
you want to get corn shipped to the
plant the plant to make whatever you got
to make in food the trucks got to spend
more for gas you got to spend more on
corn and guess what the the frackers we
are like the saudi arabia of frackers
pennsylvania whatever north dakota the
frackers
um when these prices go up now
are not going to up production
to to to have that adjustment because
they don't believe they'll be allowed to
frack under the biden regime to your
point uh about signaling and that that's
a shrewd thing then because that's like
one of the core uh principles in
economics about signaling theory
somebody actually won the nobel prize
back in in in talking about and that's
that's the problem we have and it's it's
just absurd
this is this is nuts i mean we're
sitting on on
literally with a saudi arabia of natural
gas and natural gas prices
are are through the friggin
roof that makes no sense and watching
joe biden beg
not just to the saudis but to the
russians uh i mean opec is basically
okay here's a quiz let's see see if you
guys can get this right uh so it's
probably in so
biden's has just released oil from the
strategic petroleum reserve how much how
many days or months of oil all right
lydia oh this one go
because we use 18.9 billion barrels of
gallon per day right so it's gonna last
us like two and a half days yeah yeah
boom yeah yeah to your point sigmoid
theory yeah that's really gonna drive
things down and what you know what saudi
did as soon as we did that they all said
it oh of course they cut back production
wow
they're strangling us out on purpose oh
well the saudis are like one of the
things um i regret during the trump
administration and this isn't in the
trump time book um was how the saudis
screwed our frackers
um when they started flooding the market
um with with oil yeah um and see there's
a the fracking thing there's a there's a
threshold right which is much
relatively higher than than pumping from
fields right the the traditional way the
south so so if you want to kill the
frackers you all you do is have to keep
the price of oil five bucks below that
threshold so the saudis did that they've
done that like two or three times so
real quick for people don't know there's
something called energy returned on
energy invested and fracking for a long
time didn't make sense because the cost
to actually frack wasn't worth what
you'd get out of it but when energy
prices reached a certain threshold all
of a sudden the cost stays the same but
the energy is now more valuable they
start fracking all of a sudden we find
ourselves as you mentioned the saudi
arabia fracking a lot of left-wing
activists really don't like it they're
they really don't like it but it
ultimately helps us become energy
independent
yeah and a lot of these arguments are
being made we need to stop domestic oil
production to help the environment when
in reality we're literally shipping it
from saudi arabia saudi arabia is doing
what's right for saudi arabia as of
course anyone would that's why they're
cutting out
i thought according to gen sage saudi
arabia had their own like cone where all
the carbon stays over there right yeah
of course that's how that's exactly how
it works
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you